hey everyone it's lucy here in this
video i'm going to be talking about
something i'm super passionate about
which is how you can use linkedin to
find your job in 2021 i have my linkedin
logo here i have my nanoleaf set to blue
so everything is good for the video and
i'm going to be sharing everything i
wish i had known in my first two years
of university because i really believe
that these tips will help anyone in uni
anyone looking for a job in tech and
anyone who's already in tech but looking
towards progressing their career in the
future so let's jump straight into it
alright so before you do anything on
linkedin before you start connecting
with people before you start applying to
jobs what you want to do is you want to
be optimizing your linkedin profile when
you start off on linkedin when you
create an account you have essentially a
blank canvas and it's up to you to fit
it in you fill in your profile photo
your header and also all of your
experiences as well as some background
information about you so there's so much
for you to fill in and you really have
to be strategic about first of all
making sure that you have something for
all of those key fields but also being
intentional about how you phrase all
your experiences so now that you have
your linkedin profile all set up ready
to go what you want to do is look for
jobs and i know linkedin has the classic
job tab
on the side for you to search for all
the jobs out there and it's definitely
something very powerful because the
filtering system is just amazing you can
filter by company you can filter by if
it's a full-time employment part-time
employment what you want to do though is
not just apply directly through linkedin
jobs you want to be strategic about this
because when you look at these jobs a
lot of them have you know over 100
people have applied to this job and if
you just submit an application there
it's very easy for that to be just be
lost in the amount of applications that
already have been submitted
so what you do next which brings me on
to the next tip
is to connect with people in companies
and roles that you're interested in
and let's say for example you're
interested in becoming a solutions
architect at amazon web services you
search up the title solutions architect
manager or you search up recruiter and
then you feel to buy amazon web services
and then what you do is you can start by
following them once you follow them on
linkedin you'll be able to see all the
activity if they comment on a recent job
sharing you'll be able to see that
directly on your feed and that way you
can see the top jobs that they're
recruiting for in the company now you
might be wondering well that's good and
all i know now what top jobs people are
looking for
i mean do i just apply to the job what
do i do next right so next what you do
is you
send the recruiter or hiring manager a
message letting them know that you're
interested in the company you can send
their resume through linkedin as well
through linkedin messages and i would
say typically
you don't really get a reply
half the time you do half the time you
don't just because a lot of other
students are implementing the same
strategies as well but it's definitely
good to put something in so that they
would know that you're interested in the
job and you have applied so last year i
saw on my linkedin feed that a manager
at aws was looking for an intern someone
who was able to work part-time for six
months and at that time it sounded like
a really good opportunity for me to
start my career in the tech industry so
i applied to the role i messaged the
manager asking for a half an hour coffee
chat he didn't end up directly replying
to me but he forwarded my details to the
early careers program manager who set up
a conversation with me and were able to
start the interview process basically
the day after so that was just an
example of how i was able to use
linkedin to land my first internship and
i ended up getting that internship so
that was the internship i ended up doing
last year at aws so hopefully that gave
you a bit of an insight into what
strategy you can use on linkedin to try
and stand out in the application process
but something else you can do alongside
this is to search for other people
working in the company who you can ask
to get a referral from so again you
search solutions architect on the search
bar filtered by the company and then
you'll be able to see all the solutions
architects working at amazon web
services you can send them a
personalized message asking for a
one-on-one chat maybe a half an hour
virtual coffee catcher again maybe half
of them reply half of them will just
ignore your message because we get a lot
of messages on linkedin so for the ones
that do reply set up the coffee chat
with them ask about what they do on a
day-to-day basis and ask for some tips
on how you can land a job at aws you can
send them your resume as well as the job
link that you're interested in and then
asking them for a referral and a lot of
the time most of the time people are
very willing and happy to help you out
by suggesting you for the role because
you know you've had that coffee chat
they know that you're someone who is
interested in the role and someone who
is suitable for the role as well based
on your discussions
and then
they're happy to refer you as well
because there's a referral bonus that
employees typically get if the candidate
successfully joins the company now you
might be asking me well lucy i've
applied to all these jobs and i've used
your strategies already about just
messaging people directly about the job
and also trying to get a referral but
what if we're at a period right now
where there's no jobs out there or at
least no jobs that interest me which i
totally understand because for
internships and grad roles they
typically recruit during a specific
period in the year let's say earlier on
from february to may and right now it's
august right there might not be any job
listings that interest you and there
might not be anything that you want to
really apply for and do as a role what
you can do during this period is to
slowly build up your personal brand and
also stay engaged with other people's
posts so the first one might be a bit
more trickier and you might have to
leave your comfort zone more so let's
start off with the second so the second
one is to stay engaged with other
people's posts so what you do is since
you've already you know connected with
all these people who are in companies
you're interested in keep liking their
posts
leave meaningful comments and if you see
a job that you might not be interested
in and you know a friend who might be
interested tag them below in the
comments and that way you slowly build
up a presence on linkedin because 99 of
people on linkedin don't make posts not
many people like and comment other
people's posts on a regular basis so
even just by doing that it really helps
you stand out okay so the final tip is
to start posting on linkedin and there
are so many reasons why
and there are so many reasons you might
not want to post on linkedin so let's
start off with the benefits of posting
on linkedin because honestly you
probably know most of the benefits
already it reinforces your personal
brand it helps keep a repository of
things that you've done cool things
you've worked with in the past that you
want to share with your network it helps
you get visibility in front of
recruiters hiring managers or just
people in your target industry in
general but then there's a few things
that might be stopping you you might be
scared what other people might think you
might be worried about public judgment
you might also be not really sure what
sort of posts you want to make it but
the reason you're watching this video is
because you want to get a job in tech
right and making linkedin posts is one
of the best ways to go about this so
back in may last year i made my first
ever linkedin post and i was shaking
shivering i swear i had so much anxiety
just thinking about it but the reason i
decided to make that linkedin post was
because i had a mentor who really
encouraged me what he said was as long
as your post does two things so first of
all as long as it adds value to your
linkedin network and secondly it
reinforces your personal brand then that
post is worth posting and that really
helped shift my mindset because before i
was always thinking well what are other
people going to think of me instead of
thinking what value i can bring from all
the experiences i've had in university
if i was to share that on linkedin and
help other people out along the way of
course there are going to be people who
judge you people are going to be
thinking well why is she always on
linkedin doesn't she have a life outside
of linkedin i don't know i think those
are the people who are on the extremes
there might be people who just don't
really care when they see your post
they're like oh it doesn't really apply
to me which is fine but what you want to
be targeting is that 10 or 20 of people
who are following you for your content
and who are actually gaining value from
it for example when i made a post about
six lessons i learned from my first six
months of being an amazon intern i had a
lot of people commenting down below on
how the article has really helped them
with their own internship and a lot of
messages as well from people who are
thanking me for actually creating an
article and looking back i think that
article probably took around three hours
to make but it was really worth it
because it ended up helping out a lot of
people along the way and so i guess the
main point of this is to not be afraid
of starting to post on linkedin and also
realizing that there are so many
benefits that will come out of it
alright so just to wrap up if you were
to remember one thing from this video
it's to start posting on linkedin
because linkedin will help you not just
find a job in tech but also
be something that would help you build
up a personal brand in the long run i
really hope this video was insightful to
some of you who are looking for a job in
tech this is just a lot of things that i
wish i had known in my first couple of
years when i was looking for jobs and if
you have any questions or comments
please leave it down below if you found
this video helpful in any way leave it a
like and subscribe to this channel to
stay updated with more tech career and
student advice bye for now